[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual fall
chefs classic hello chess fans you are
looking live at the boardroom in the
tournament hall at the st. Louis chess
club the world-famous st. Louis chess
club and we have some heavy hitters in
there today for you 2,500 2,600 level
players are all in combat and they have
been for a couple of hours so come on in
and stay a while as we give you
up-to-date information on the games my
name is Ben Simon and my name is Eric
Rosen and I'm excited to begin the
tournament and looking forward to some
exciting exciting days of chess yeah I
mean a lot of your favorite baseball
teams might be out of the playoffs but
you're in luck because this is the fall
chess classic and this is a one of the
quarterly classic tournaments here at
the st. Louis chess club where we have
two fields one is the really strong 2600
field and the other is the 24 2,500
usually and there's anything from norms
on the line there's pride glory a lot of
money so it's very exciting chess and
we're gonna be bringing you abbreviated
coverage of all nine days of this event
for 90 minutes every day and then at the
end we will we'll take it to its finale
no matter how long it goes I must say
it's good to be back to first time doing
commentary it was for the summer classic
just a few months ago I was doing it
with woman Grandmaster Catarina and
Silva who unfortunately is not here
pursuing a PhD somewhere in on this
planet but it's good to be with you Ben
and I do want to say in order to get off
to a good start I got you a gift it's
it's a pumpkin celebrating the fall
season it is a pumpkin oh well thanks
man you shouldn't have done that
wowser man this is a really great
pumpkin
where is the stem there's no stem it was
only pumpkin that was that was perfectly
round or almost perfectly round and it
only cost 99 cents at Whole Foods so
pretty cheap there got a discount on it
this is good this is uh this is very
themed Halloween's intention thank you
what's out further ado let's take a look
at our player roster for our masters
division its group a oh man okay so
here's what we have here world rank on
the left side we have a lot we have six
top 100 players in this field and we
have Eric Hanson - who's interactive but
very strong field eight Federation's are
represented in this group Eric what do
you make of this I mean when I first
look at it it's hard to imagine that
Eric Hanson can be inactive he's
hyperactive on online a very prolific
streamer and he just came back from the
Olympiad so I'm sure he's he's warmed up
hopefully for him not burnt out and I'm
sure it may be he's still recovering
from jet lag but there are a few other
players coming back from the Olympiad -
ray Robson most notably on the the US
team having just won the silver medal
and Alexander Lenderman who was a coach
for the US team so it seems like a few
players in this section might have some
jetlag to come over do you have a pick
in this section right off the bat I mean
it's the type of field where anyone can
win I mean look at the ratings or
they're pretty close like the biggest
star differential if we look at
Lenderman and Robson there are only
about 60 points between them so I feel
like this it usually comes down to form
who's in the sharpest shape I would
either have to pick ray or Cobian I know
they've been working very hard lately
and they're just outside of the elite
group of three u.s. players behind the
the magic three of Fabiano Hikaru and
Mosley so I I know both of them are
making a push to at some point get to
2,700 right right yeah I go with a co
peon - he always has really great
performances here in st. Louis and I
really
what I think he was seeded number eight
there and I think that's gonna be a
really big deal for him in this event
and don't forget he was on the verge of
winning the summer chess classic yes but
lost in a very exciting arm again and
playoff so I'm sure he's he's looking to
do better than the last tournaments he's
actually the only returning Classic
champion from the series that we have
held so best of luck to all the players
of course and Akopian let's take a look
at our challengers section in Group B 24
2500 level players we have five
Federation's represented in this group
and you'll notice there are eight
grandmasters International Master
Brandon Jacobson has just been awarded
that title after he earned it that just
came days ago in Batumi he at the fitti
Congress he was awarded the I M title
and then if either master Christopher
you and those two have norms that they
can earn in this event that's true
Brandon Jacobson being an IM can has
potential for for IM norton's and
christopher you is an FM he has
potential for both and I am no or a GM
nor him and we should note that I
believe Christopher you already has two
I am yours and he has a 2400 rating so
if he gets his final norm in this event
he can he can get the International
master titled this could be a big event
for him but it would be very impressive
if he wins that you know they make you
work for those titles there right I'm
sure I know myself
yes it can be a challenge do you know
how many points Christopher needs to get
the I am norm charissa for you he needs
to earn four points you can get the last
norm that's doable that's a minus one
score you could draw all all but one of
those games lose last game and still get
in Norman let's become more familiar
with the tournament format this is a
double knot a double round-robin but the
210 player round robins and the time
control is 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then 30 minutes added on for
the remainder of the game after that
there is a 30 second increment for
move number 1 which means that all
players are required to take notation
from the very beginning to the very end
and also there is a 30 move draw rule in
effect the players cannot agree to a
draw until after Black's 30th move and
this is so the players play fighting
chess
Tony rich the arbiter up in the
tournament hall and the executive
director here at the club said I don't
mind draws but at least play fighting
chess and that's what it's all about
that's true yes so the games can go
quite long with the increment the no
draw role and the added time after
before thee and let's take a look at the
tournament schedule we're gonna be here
for nine days there are no rest days so
buckle up 11:00 a.m. on the first day
and the last day last day is to make
room for playoffs if we need them
because there can only be one winner in
each section every other day the rounds
begin at 1:00 p.m. you should follow the
games as they happen at us chess champs
calm now you'll notice we're on the air
a little bit late and we will be every
day we have an abbreviated 90-minute
show for you that starts with the games
in progress and may end with the games
in progress if game clinchers are not
still in the tournament hall so we will
be on Iran today at 1:30
we'll be on it the last day at 1:30
Central time and then 3:30 Central Time
all the other days so we hope that you
can join us it's gonna be a lot of fun
yeah and I just want to give a shout out
to everyone watching online from all
over the world we have streams up on
both YouTube and twitch and we will be
taking a glance of the YouTube chat in
the twitch chat so if people have
questions or you just want to say hi
feel free to interact with us there yeah
and be sure to use the hashtag fall
chess Classic to join the conversation
and right now I can tell you that in our
YouTube chat piggy pig-pig said I love
Mike comer my favorite international
arbiter so thank you piggy pig-pig it's
very kind yes now there are games in
progress and actually one game has
already finished let's take a look at
the pairings in group a this is what
it's all about
we have grandmaster
yeah yoon Ludvig hammer i asked all the
players how to say their names oh my
goodness this is embarrassing it's a
challenge it is we have hammer taking on
Grandmaster chess brah
Eric Hanson grandmaster alexei gribov
taking on Lazaro Birds on Eureka Zubov
taking on Alex Linderman arusian Akopian
versus Ray Robson and our game of the
day in Group A that's right we have
Darius weirds against Grandmaster cetera
man I believe so the Ramones
first time playing in st. Louis hero
arrived just a few days ago and both of
these are incredibly strong players if
we take a look at the current position
they had a somewhat quiet opening with
Queens getting traded very early on from
a Catalan structure but if we go forward
just a few moves here after night to b5
rook ACH white planted this knight on a
very beautiful square in the heart of
last territory on d6 attacking the rook
attacking the bishop attacking the b7
pawn after black played a simple rook to
c7 white played a very fiery move might
take b7 and just but I'm saying at this
position it kind of makes my head hurts
because there's a lot of things on your
attack we can see that the knight is
attacked by the rook but but the bishop
is staring down along the long diagonal
the rooks are staring each other on the
D file and for the last last 13 or so
minutes spirits has been thinking in
this position perhaps trying to
calculate the concrete variations and
unfortunately for me I'm not able to say
what the outcome is going to be there is
uh I think there's a lot of different
captures to calculate so we'll
definitely want to keep an eye on this
game indeed we will now there the other
section is ongoing as well Group B a
challengers division let's take a look
at the pairings here st. Lewisohn
Grandmaster Akshat Chandra taking on
Grandmaster Sergei Azeroth Christopher
you the Vita master who has a title to
earn in this event taking on the other
youngster Brandon Jacobson the newly
I am and then the rest are all
grandmasters Alshon more ADEA body the
former Grand Master in res here at the
Chess Club taking on another Grand
Master in res Danish Boros of Hungary
Ashwin Jha ROM takes on Conrad Holt and
then our game of the day in Group B yeah
Stevens irk against grandmaster Havana's
caboose Ian I think both of these
players have contention to win the event
I must say that Steven is my top pick
given that he's performed very well in
st. Louis in the past he's played a
number of the the Grand Master norm
invitationals I know he scored norms at
these tournaments with very impressive
scores and now he's he's in a section
with some pretty top guns so we'll see
if he can keep up the st. Louis momentum
have you seen got booze Ian before I
have not that's a new name for me I
believe he's from Armenia that's correct
yeah and and he's the highest rated he's
the highest rated and I don't believe
he's played in st. Louis before I think
there's a good number of players where
this is their first time playing in st.
Louis so there might be some adjustments
just acclimating to the environment and
the timezone and just overall
surroundings well what does the game
look like so far in in that matchup yeah
if we take a look at the current
position I was I was pretty impressed
with Steven Dirk's opening it came from
one of my favorite openings a London
system where we see this very kind of
traditional London structure and at this
point I like to even set up these two
bishops glaring down at the Queen side
the open C file for whites if we go
forward to see how the game unfolded
after rook to c8
Queens to be one like before it seemed
like black was playing a bit more
actively and then after Bishop takes e7
there were quite a number of trades rook
takes he won all the rooks got traded
and then 93 so black went down upon but
it's getting a lot of initiative with
with the knight attacking both the Queen
and the dish up after
Queen 2d one night I got for you take f4
if we look at this physician and count
the pawns white is up upon but but the
structure doesn't seem to aesthetic for
whites and actually I would encourage
the viewers to pause the the board or
pause the video here and try and find
the simple tactic for black to win back
upon if we know thus a'queen is
defending the pawn on d4 but it is tied
down to also defending the e1 square
which is targeted by the the black queen
so this is what we call in chess being
overworked where the the light queen is
simply doing too many jobs at once after
Bishop take T for the Queen cannot
recapture due to checkmates on e 1 so it
seems like black won back the pawn after
Bishop f3 d6 and h4 this brings us to
the current position where it's equal
material but it's obstacle our bishops
so sometimes this will create some
drawing chances but I mean if I had to
pick a side I would have to pick back in
this position we should also note look
at the time situation run in 27 what
you'd pick black because of the the
pawns being more coherent and structured
yeah sometimes when you look at pawn
structure you want to look at pawn
islands and also like double pawns in
this case black has a very nice large
pawn island extending on the Kings side
keeping the bakhtin quite safe these
double pawns on f4 for white combined
with this advanced pawn in h4 it's a bit
weakening to the king and we should also
note that especially the pawn in f2 can
be a long-term target as it's just kind
of stuck on the dark square and it can
be constantly attacked by this Bishop on
d4 so I wouldn't be surprised if black
plays a simple move soon like Queen c5
or Queen b6 and just tries to further
optimize a position and really put the
pressure on White's given that Steven
only has less than 2 minutes to make 13
more moves yeah for caboose yeah that's
very scenic pawn island
deed well you know some of these players
are professionals and their students but
none of them are playing for free and
there is more than just pride and glory
on the line let's take a look at the
prize fund for our top group 22 grand in
total on the line Eric not too bad
that's a lot of money it makes me wish
that I was playing in this event but I
guess there's a reason why I mean I'm in
the commentary room and not in the
playing hall someday someday and how
about the prize fund for Group B it's
not too shabby as well very generous
prize fund with the first place we're
going home with four thousand dollars
that can buy a lot of pumpkins maybe at
the end of this tournament we'll have to
take a trip to the pumpkin patch and
stock up for Halloween it is Halloween
is the season now that you mention it do
you think we might see a Halloween cabin
at some point know about this event no
it is a dubious opening - would you play
it just for the gimmick I would consider
it the do the Halloween gambit is
dubious if you play it as white but
there's a version as black you can play
like a reverse Halloween gamete which is
actually quite quite playable maybe I
can show it real quick sure it's going
back here ignore the names for the time
being we don't want anyone to assume
that these players are going into such a
such a crazy line but the Halloween
gambit for for white is when white
sacrifices not a pawn but a piece on e5
Knight 85 is a start of the Halloween
now I think it's called the Halloween
gambit because it looks scary like
White's pawn center is quite terrifying
and there's many variations where if the
light moves away then the pawns can keep
rolling down the board and white argues
that there's some compensation for
having a large pawn center even though
white is down the knight but then
there's a reverse version of the
Halloween gambit where if we go back a
couple moves here and let's say white
plays pawn to g3 black can can basically
do the same thing sacrifice a knight on
e4 after Knight a key for D
five and this is actually a better
version for black because white does not
have this retreating move Knight to g3
the pawn is actually misplaced on g3 so
if we were to see a Halloween gambit I
would think it would occur from this
line but I think the odds are are quite
slim yeah I would say so very very
thematic okay so we have one game that
has already finished bar Cogan and Ray
Robson have have battled to a draw in a
row end game yeah I know these these
players have played many times before in
US Championship events and in the past
actually their most recent game was
notorious just marathon game where
version tried to claim threefold
repetition didn't end up claiming it
correctly then Ray was the one who
eventually won checkmating with a bishop
at night this game seemed a lot more
calm seemed like they went into a pretty
theoretical Greenfeld line where
everything just traded off and we're
left with a almost symmetrical just keen
pawn or Brooklyn ending just a dead draw
okay so as we look through the games
here it has anything caught your eye
Eric I am always looking at my little
thermometer here on my own computer to
see if there is one game that's really
just sticking out I mean the the game
between the two youngsters seems very
very sharp very dynamic it is funny
they're playing together on this first
day here yeah we have a couple
interesting matchups I mean the two
youngest players in Group B are facing
up off between Christopher you and
Brandon Jacobson and then later we
should take a look at the game in Group
A between hammer and Hansen because era
they're both from the cold climate areas
and they're both prolific streamers so
it seems like some of the the matchups
that these opponents have a lot in
common if we take a look at the position
here I do want to go back and see the
opening it did come from one of the
sharpest lines in the north where
White's castles queenside and it seemed
like black just left the king in the
center for most of the game after Bishop
takes f6 pawn take f6 these central
pawns do act as a good somewhat shelter
for the backing going forward here it's
White's intention to destroy the pawn
shelter going for this f5 move which is
a double-edged move because it aims to
destabilize upon an e6 but at the same
time it gives away this seemingly
valuable e5 square and we can imagine
that quite soon the knight will jump
into e5 and be a very stable outpost in
the center going forward here pawn h5
Bishop d3 Queen b6 white plate King b1
which is a favorite rule of been fine
gold famous saying is always play King
b1 makes a lot of sense in this position
to get off any potential x-ray vision on
the C file and make sure the King is
just well-guarded for if if there's
scenarios where the position opens up
even further and seem like black is a
one seizing the initiative first with
pawn before 92 and a5 just keep the
pawns for him coming ideas of a4 cops
kicking the night maybe even future
possibilities of b3 it's to bust open
the Queen side Queen e1 was played a
four did come 92 so it seems like why
does getting pushback like we can see
the knight retreats the Queen retreated
so I am impressed with the way that
Jacobsen is playing in this position 95
another forward attacking move and now
it's time for Christopher to perhaps try
and regroup and optimize the pieces
Knight f3 played and seems like Brandon
wasted no chaat no time going for the
immediate pawn b3 which is not even a
sacrifice like sometimes when when a
pawn break like this is played it's
aiming to sacrifice a pawn to open up
some file but in this case this pawn on
b3 is supported by both the pawn on e4
and the Queen and it seems like some
file is guaranteed to open up after C
tech p38
III I do like the move that Christopher
you played in this position claw and a
three
whenever you're the one defending you
want to try and keep the position as
close as possible pond III keeps keeps
at a and B file relatively closed for
the time being but it seems like this
pawn on b3 is going to be somewhat of a
long-term headache for whites as it's
not the easiest pawn to remove and after
rook G 893 and this brings us to the
current position they're only on move 22
and okay we see that Jacobsen just
played another move there can't quite
make out what it is but it seems like
both players are running low on time and
I wouldn't be surprised that there's a
time scramble to come with with 18 move
18 more moves to play until time control
yeah they're playing pretty rapidly oh
look there we're getting a little bit of
a closer look of that board oh wow
okay stuff happened after so after rook
G 893 seems like Jacobsen went for the
trade of night for Bishop taking on d3
rook to e3 and then his rook swoops down
into c2 I'm sure this was planned ahead
of time the intention was to remove the
bishop from defending C - and now the
rook is a very annoying piece on c2
controlling the second drink supported
by the the pawn on b3 and okay speaking
of Halloween earlier this seems quite
terrifying for for the white side with
this combination of b3 pawn and work on
c2 if I'm not sure what what White's
gonna do here how does how does Brandon
is Brandon gonna just bring in more on
the C file clean in the rook I mean
that's the thing that like the rook
alone can't carry through the whole
attack like the black is going to need
more attackers and I'm not entirely sure
what the immediate follow-up will be I
mean it might just be that he wants to
take on g2 maybe not immediately attack
the white king that just went upon and
it's up to white
perhaps you with the stress we might see
a move like rook g1 or queen f1 feels a
little bit passive these are types of
positions I don't like to play myself
because they're so double-edged and it's
always a question you do you hold on to
material or you go for counter play
another move that white might be
considering here is something like
Knight d4 just to centralize the Knights
put pressure on on the e6 pawn but also
attack both the rook and the b3 pawn and
this actually looks like a pretty
reasonable move to to consider we can
imagine things could get a bit messy if
the rook takes on g2 this rook might be
going a bit too far into White's
territory there might be some idea like
Queen f1 to chop the rook I should note
that I'm not using an engine myself so
these types of lines that the computer
can crunch through and find perhaps the
exact and best continuation but for a
mere human to figure everything out
especially with the time ticking it's
not so easy so I wouldn't be surprised
if there's mistakes or more more
fireworks to come and also to remind all
of you out there if you're watching on
YouTube exclusively you can also check
out the YouTube stream that's embedded
at us chess champs calm where we have
the chess 24 module up there and you can
turn on the engine thermometer or you
could turn it off if it's not your thing
so follow along with us there at us
chess champ comm that's true some people
like to watch just with the engine
always running some people don't like
any engine interference keep it fresh
and and also avoid the laziness of just
just seeing the top engine move and just
assuming the valuation is always correct
when I like when I watch chess I like to
first look at the game without an engine
and then then after I come to my own
conclusions sometimes I'll turn the
engine
but it can vary right okay well let's
take a look at the game but between the
two streamers yeah let's do it the
hammer and the chess Brock sure these
are two fan favorites scrolling here to
find the game we can see them in the
playing hall they're playing right
beside the window but with a low mark if
it's silhouetted they have the best spot
in that that turnip hall I'm telling you
what it's kind of dark up there because
they have some of the wind the window
blinds closed I don't know if that's a
request to the players on the left side
of the screen there's some windows that
are closed but I'd like to plan a nice
bright spot that's true like sometimes
the lighting can be quite harsh
especially if it's a sunny day it was
actually raining earlier and it was
cloudy so you would think the light is a
bit more diffused and I think it's worse
off my beautiful day here in st. Louis
outside I mean I just not too sunny and
not to overcast it's just great I mean
apart from the rain this is what we want
is something cool nothing like that 90
degree weather in in August so yeah
let's take a look at the game we can see
a very imbalance position perhaps we
could start with the opening because
they did play a variation of the night
or if I know Hansen is is known for
playing the knight RF and Hammer plays a
somewhat sticky move g3 not one of the
main lines but still a very playable
line and after pong e5 I believe the
main move here for white is Knight de 2
usually to keep this diagonal more open
for the bishop coming to to g2 also
having ideas of knights to d5 followed
by Knight ec3 but hammer played a very
peculiar and move here Knight f3 which
I'll admit I've never seen before
it seems seems like a strain square for
the Knights because the night is a bit a
bit dominated by this pawn structure
with E 5 D 6 I don't see that the clear
future for the night right away the
knight also blocks the bishops diagonal
it also blocks F pawn from
moving so we'll have to see how the game
unfolded maybe one thing I could
anticipate is that if if hammer would
like to reposition his knight maybe a
potential idea is 92 94 93 to control
the d5 square but let's see what happens
after Bishop to e7 Bishop g2 okay so
both sides complete development and then
hammer goes straight away for 95 very
common move in these types of positions
and then after Bishop e7 now there are
somewhat strange move from whites this
Knight looks like one of the best pieces
in the position but hammer went ahead
and traded it off for one of blacks
obvious pieces in this position the
bishop on e7 which literally has no
moves and he trades it off for a very
centralized night I think he did this
because there was simply too much
pressure on d5 the fact that there is
already two attackers and also the fact
that even though it seems like a maybe
not the best trade in the current moment
if you can win the bishop hair it can be
very beneficial in the long term given
that that if the position opens up
further and white has the only dark
squared bishop on the board the c1
bishop can come to life later on in the
game so let's go forward here in I take
you seven Queen take e7 and now we see
the idea of the night heading to h4
seems like an perhaps saw a future
possibility of of 9.5 or as I'm sure you
would know what would thank fine quilts
say here
nice it tributes it to someone else as
well does he yes who is the first
creator of that that's saying I wish I
could tell us in the YouTube chat where
does knife at five come from he says in
every video this is shameful I'm sorry
gotten final even has a twitch emote of
knife f5 so I just assumed it was been
who who created that but I could be
wrong
the director Danny Machuca says it's
Petronius Lucilius petróleos the greek
degree chiyan interesting
Thanks Oh could be so we need we need
confirmation on that
anyway 9.5 495 5 is a tremendous threat
in this position to target the black
queen and also target this backward pawn
on d6 so Queen e6 is played and white
improves like White House to grab still
baby sickness before pawn 97 the zoom
forward here because many more moves
have been played both sides trying to
optimize their position it was not my
intention to bring up been Feingold so
much but he has enough another famous
saying which I'm sure you're very
handsome out of famous Saenz the never
player 3 this case f3 actually looks
very ugly but maybe it was necessary
because black had three attackers on the
for pawn and the problem for a white is
this Queen is leading the battery
usually when you have a battery when
pieces are lined up you don't want your
most powerful piece leading the battery
and in this case black was threatening
Knight a key force so maybe that's what
provoked pawn off three seemingly ugly
move but perhaps necessary in the
position going forward here f3 and e5
actually really like to play by by Erich
cancer and I think even though White has
a bishop pair it's Hansen who's who's
really taking the initiative and
carrying the momentum in his favor
I really like the harmony with with all
of his pieces it seems like everything
is working together incredibly well the
main focus of course being the pawn on
e4 now there's four attackers on e4 and
hammer was provoked to take on d5 Bishop
take d5 let's go forward even further
here white did attempt to try and
consolidate and unwind a little bit
rook AC 185 and now we see perhaps the
first actually active move from hammer
Bishop to h3 a nice little sneaky idea
the the benefit of having the Queen on
f1 given that the Bishop is defended
and it seems like a nice skewer from
from light there's many pieces lined up
along this diagonal why it's not winning
anything but at least he's fighting for
control of some squares in Black's
territory and I can imagine that 9f5
could come relatively soon queen c6 was
played and then okay things seem to open
up even more after pawn c4 a very
explosive move B takes c4 b takes c4
bishop takes c4 if i'm counting
correctly black just won a pawn in that
variation but has walked into a pin so
let's see how the game unfolds Queen f2
Queen a6 knife f5 rook c6 takes us to
the final position they're on move 26
they have 14 more moves to reach move 40
and gain that extra half-hour it is
hammer to move and I am trying to
evaluate this position it seems like
White has a little bit of compensation
for being gone a pawn but I don't think
it's that much and I still really like
the way that Hanson has been playing in
this game
I mean his pieces still seem very
coordinated I like the Queen and Bishop
battery kind of piercing through White's
territory and everything seems to be
defending everything there's not a
single piece in this position
that's undefended for black so nice
defend each other the roof defends e5
this rook defends everything the Queen's
offends the a pawn so it's not clear
what white will be targeting with with
the moves to come you know the lifetime
score between these players there's no
strict there are no strangers to each
other in this particular match we have
hammer getting the better of Hanson at 9
games to 7 I'm sorry
11 games to 9 with seven drawers so very
familiar they should be with each other
these players it's true and I'm I'm sure
the lifetime score you're referring to
does not take into account
I'm sure the
several if not like hundreds of games
that they play on chess comm know both
of them are I mean are very active
streamers and I know they play in all
the the chess calm streamer tournaments
so I wouldn't be surprised if they've
they fight hundreds of games on Josh
calm it would be interesting to see that
statistic I don't know if we can see
like the lifetime score against to check
on users but maybe we can get the people
in the back to look up some stats for us
yeah maybe we could so we have some we
have an update here in the top
seiga boozy ins game in Group B it looks
like he is a vaana's caboose Ian of
Armenia is doing very well
against Stephen Zurich yeah I liked his
position earlier and it seems like he's
been growing his advantage and with
Stephen solo on time I mean he's still
struggling to stay above a minute and I
mentioned earlier that sometimes ox of
color bishops have the tendency to be a
bit Wragge
but in a position like this the office
of Clark bishops favor the side who's
attacking if favor is the side whose
King is more safe and in this case
White's King is very unsafe on h3 he's
begging for a shelter and meanwhile
white seems completely tied down I mean
the the Queen on f3 is tied down to two
different mating ideas if the Queen were
to vanish from f3 there'd be potential
for black to play either a queen take g3
mates or queen h1 mates so this Queen
needs to stay on f3 and as black here I
would you be looking for some way to
just keep applying the pressure and try
and perhaps distract the Queen away from
defending I'm being told that gobos Ian
just played h4 h4 yeah we see that on
the board and Stephens time is ticking
h4 looks like a very nice move and
Qaboos Ian gets all off away from the
board with Steven below a minute
and we can see Steven hand on his face
not looking so comfortable he has less
than 30 seconds left it seems like I
mean the media threat is is simply to
take on g3 either with the pawn or with
the bishop I am a bit curious what the
GU boos Ian's idea is if white takes
back G take h4 I see that was not played
you catch the move here oMG for Queen g4
mg4 check okay it's not a bad move to
try and gain some time
sometimes when you can play a check and
you're so low on time might as well do
so to gain some the extra 30 seconds on
the clock now black is needing to got
out of check here but it seems like the
king can find a safe place on f8 I'm a
bit surprised could Busey and got a like
walked away from the board given that he
should be playing quickly to put the
pressure back on Stephen I wouldn't be
surprised if King f8 is played rather
quickly here and then it's still going
to be a question how white deals with so
much pressure against this g3 pond I
mean there are three attackers if if
King f8 is played and GTH four is played
maybe I can give this to you as a puzzle
black to move and checkmate in one move
Queen h1 yeah h1 and game would be over
so the pawn can't take on h4
I would be interested if Queen to h4 it
looks like Queen each one can still be
played and then the king is beginning a
journey up the board pawn a five could
be played but then king h5 and maybe the
white king is actually finding safety in
blacks territory a very strange position
going back here we see GU Busey and is
not playing King f8 right away he is
taking his time I mean there's only
three legal moved here to consider if
there's King f8 there's King h7 which I
don't think he wants to play at all and
whenever there's obstacles you don't
want to put your king on the color
square of the the pawns Bishop given
that Bishop d3 would be an additional
check so I would imagine he's deciding
between King f8 and King h8 and I'm
trying to figure out if there's a
benefit to having the King on h8 rather
than f8 but it just seems wow he plays
King h7 as a move I least expected seems
quite strange I'm trying to figure out
why would he put his King on the light
square
maybe Bishop d3 check isn't so venomous
because f5 could be played and maybe he
wants to keep his King on h7 to defend
the H pawn in some situations the
pressure is clearly back on Stephen he
takes the H pawn with his Queen so we
are going to enter a similar line and
after Queen h1 King to g4 play is coming
pretty rapidly
now Queenie for not a check but it seems
like a very powerful improving of
hitting the bishop and and improving the
Queen and there's some funny mating
ideas here if the bishop moves to a
normal square like like f3 then it would
be an immediate game over as Queen I 5
is a pretty esthetic checkmates it seems
like White's pieces are trying to
shelter the king but they're actually
getting in the way as a king is just
completely boxed outs and the Queen a
black Queen controls all the squares
around the White King so Stephen has to
make a decision here his bishops
attacked where to move the bishop
doesn't seem like there's any counter
play
and it seems like there's only a few
safe squares for the bishop you can
retreat to d1 or f1 it could lunge
forward to be five or a six but then it
would be very out of play I do want to
mention here that black has a couple
ways but to potentially win this
position of course one way is to get
some sort of mating attack given that
there is already a fairly nice mating
net around the white king but on top of
that black has the only pass pawn on the
board the this d5 pawn and for the time
being there's nothing immediately in its
way
the pawn can start running and then it's
up to white deal with the pawn running
down the board and to deal with the fact
that the King is just so unsafe on g4 so
I would be quite scared here here as as
white in this position so Stephen just
played bishop d1 and made the time
control so now there's 30 minutes added
on to his clock as you see but how long
do you think he's gonna survive yeah
well it's a miracle that he made time
control and seemingly survive the danger
given that the Kings on g4 and it
doesn't seem like there's any immediate
win for black if you take a look at the
last move played Queen d3 so it's
another simple attacking move and even
though they made time control kibou Z
and just play this quite quickly and now
look at this Bishop on d1
I mean Bishop's are usually pieces that
have a lot of mobility but in this
position the bishop is just so misplaced
it's attacked by the Queen it's
essentially trapped I don't see where
the bishop can move it can't move to c2
it can't move to e to the where the
worst squared possible would be Bishop
f3 just to reiterate that queen of five
is mate so question is how does white
save the bishop I only see one move in
this position
to defend the bishop which is queen h1
but that looks quite sad
give him the queen on h1 the bishop on
d1 and the king being the most active
piece on g4 usually you want you want it
the other way around where the king is
is safe on the back rank and the more
major pieces are active if we calculate
concretely here it seems like black
should have calculating some force twin
actually it looks like forst forst win
of a queen if black plays Queen on 5 the
King would have two legal moves if King
got three there'd be Queenie for winning
the Queen and they just shook who
Stephen just resigned yeah the game is
over yeah because if king h4 there is a
very sneaky move Queen take out four and
black is taking advantage of this pawn
being pinned from behind by the bishop
on f2 and White's just getting mated or
I mean if King h5 there's Queen g5 if
King h3 there's Queen g3 mates when I
teach younger kids I like to call this
mate that in-your-face mates just make
us face yeah now I don't encourage kids
to say in your face when they played
this checkmates but one of the most
classic mates in chess and one of my
favorite picks for the term in Stevens
ERK going down quite brutally and in the
first round we should probably get the
top seat of Group B huh finest caboose
Ian's in here what do you think that
sounds like a good idea I see they're
both I've left the flank Hall the board
is now empty there is that our first a
slice of game yes ours blood of the
tournament in either meal the two groups
and by the way if you're if you're just
now joining us this is the 2018 fall
chess classic my name is Ben Simon and
I'm joined by international master and
notable chess streamer Eric Rosen and
we're happy that you're here with us for
day one round one of this very strong
two round-robin event
okay so we just had one game finish
let's see if we have you know who the
most stylish person in this event is no
[ __ ]
wait I'm trying to think your grave
isn't playing no wait what do we call it
I'm blinking the door the fedora yeah
yeah over the battery community yeah
let's take a look at his game he's
playing no I should know he also just
came back from the Olympiad yes I didn't
know this until a few days ago but he
was coaching now I'm blanking again he
was coaching a team from some country
some smaller country
he was also helping his fiance and
former US Women's Champions to be in the
foyer for the u.s. women's team so maybe
he still has some jet lag to come over
to well he you know some of these
players haven't been feeling well you
know there's jet lag and there's also
like coughs going around I know there's
several people it like even they hear at
the club so you know it's you got to do
your best during these events to kind of
stay chipper well it's good that they're
quarantined in the playing Hall and
we're safe in the commentary just have
to just make sure that we don't let any
of the sick ones into the studio but
yeah sometimes this happens with the
change of weather and if I'm going to
get sick during the tournament I would
prefer to get sick before tournaments
and so I'm I'm not getting sick during
or towards the end of the tournaments
because these these events can be quite
long and exhausting I do want to take a
look at this game between Dennis and Al
Sean let's go back here and see how it
unfolded they did come from a Catalan
structure I do want to note that the
Catalan has been a recurring opening
this round trademarked by this Bishop on
g2 white having a nice
base advantage and if we go forward and
see how the game unfolded white just
kept the space advantage it seemed like
fur for most of the game advancing with
Pawnee 5 which is a somewhat double
edged move when the pawn attacks tonight
white is gaining more space but it does
give away this nice outpost square on d5
which aurash is happy to take going
forward here in night take t5 removing
the outpost and transforming the pawn
structure Queen e2 a5 and Bishop to f1
perhaps realizing the bishop wasn't too
useful on g2 and going for the attack
against the b-pawn now we will get to
the scheme later but I do want to go
back to the game that just finished
between Stevens urk and Havana's boo
boos Ian we are joined by LaVon Hayes in
the studio did I say your name correctly
yeah so welcome to st. Louis and
congratulations for winning your first
game I do want to ask is this your first
time playing at the same which is and
where do you live right now I'm studying
in Texas in University of Texas Rio
Grande Willie it's in Brownsville ah
very nice this is your first year
studying there oh yeah I'm a freshman
okay well how's how's it your been going
so far you busy with academics are you
able to balance well sometimes I have
some trouble either to decide to play
some tournaments or to concentrate on my
exams but time is enough I understand
that yeah I'm a recent graduate from
Western University I can very much
relate balancing shacking and is that
most of them with good time management
it's all about time management and
discipline too so I do want to have you
take us through the game and it seemed
like seemed like you had just a really
nice position resulting from this Queen
and Bishop ending now I want to ask was
a London opening a line that you were
expecting
well my opponent was playing either a4
or d4 and Bishop f4 on
I was prepared like more or less and I
chose this variation I want to talk
about move after seventh black smoke I'm
after several CD Queen b6 mhm and hear
about b3 move like it's not a huge
positional mistake but it gives some
weak squares on coincide so position
should be a more or less equal because
like what later develop normally but
before like gives me some squares
sometimes on c3 sometimes on a3 maybe
Quinn before usually in the structures
well white prefer to put pone on a tree
and have night on t3 so well it's not a
huge mistake but later my contour play
was mostly depended on this book squares
so let me ask you what was alternative
to be I thinking about even some bone
sacrifice maybe like some Knight d2 like
Queen B - Knight c4 and now it's not
that easy to play after a queen before
for example Knight ft - so I was
thinking about Queen b5 immediately to
be honest I'm not sure the birth
disposition about its evaluation because
well I was thinking if he plays Knight B
D - maybe I'll play d5 I mean now before
because when your night is developed on
D - it's already useful to have pawn on
d5 it's like taking nice squares maybe
some other possibility was to play Queen
d2 and after 94 to play Queen C - mm-hmm
seems like a position that you would
rather prepare ahead of time I'm playing
like a patient with white opal it colors
I'm having usually one more tempo but
it's not something huge it's like
sometimes a little advantage sometimes
slightly better for mm so it should be
cool I'm not sure about the correction
after Queen b6 but to be honest I does I
don't like b3 yeah I did seem a bit
weakening and it seemed like later in
the game maybe mistake but this gives me
some easy play after in many variations
like weakening citrus claritin well
let's go forward to the middle game
because when we glanced at this position
earlier there may be uh
Bishop f5 I was thinking about some f5
move it's consistent already weakened is
diagonal a 188 so well I'm I was worried
most little more some like Bishop g5
maybe not taking Connie five because if
what happens if i take spoken text x95
ruby eight you're a bully
quincy one i work when you want cuz
quincy to Bishop f5 is a temple insured
mmm maybe even 95
alright there is some interest position
like 95 night before takes takes it
seems like there's a lot of potential
for yeah but I was I thought maybe I'm
okay but I there was other option for
white on if I have to play some Bishop
g5 mhm yeah but because was with the bit
remove I just prefer to play normally
with Bishop f5 and I thought if in other
positions are normal so with before
maybe it's even little better for me
rooks you want a plate rook F see it
because I want to have my queen and
eight it can be hanging on bistec
sometimes I see yeah this move was
against effort because now what was
written completely foreign we should be
three aha
yeah it seems a bit unusual to put the
bishop so deep in my territory and then
eventually just give away the bishop
pair where when we were taking a look
earlier I preferred white with these two
bishops with maybe I I miss evaluated
the position if the problem is like
white don't have space where King pony's
not an h3 oh it usually opens in these
positions after the like Bishop f4 what
usual place time x-ray and here we like
h2 8 a to pawn is hanging so I depended
on my calculations because you are right
if white have some time to play like H
where Roxie one it will be a little
better for right that's why I played
here Queenie five otherwise for example
a
position was no Ramallah I mean what
don't have these problems I would play
d5 d6 and try to hold the position I see
yeah it seemed like you made use of kind
of the temporary after Kuna fight that's
why I played and well here I think that
was the one of the main mistakes for a
while to get that position because here
he gave me the C file and the doctrines
was maybe instead of Roxy one play to
play other route to see one yeah I
thought it was possibility for block to
soccer take 1 ay 2 coz he can play rook
3 C 2 and later in d5 so 25 G 5 yeah so
that's why I have to play firstly 5
instead of taking cone a - and now
Bishop III and Queen e2 next what we
need to be like bishop defy bringing
bishop sick I'm not sure about the
position but it's not a huge advantage
so I decided to play I mean maybe that
was the better option for a white and
I'm not sure yeah I mean it seemed like
he just he played a bit cheap-ass oh
yeah no I have to see so it's of course
not winning but it's and especially at
this moment my open start cuz I'm a time
trouble
so that was easier for me to play yeah
it seemed like a combination of factors
just you had this kind of slight pole in
the position combined attack positions
with time travel and Bishop e7 was a
great mistake already I'm sure about the
options maybe but it was better to play
Bishop d3
and try to hold position is confident
yeah because now after Bishop d7 how it
happened
take some take takes in 93 it's already
very unpleasant position
yeah it's thinking if Queens got traded
there'd be some hope for a draw of
course it's but I'm never gonna trade
the Queen see of course you're with all
always I wanted training some attack and
it seemed like relatively smooth
conversion I mean he he was quite low on
time already by this point and
and here we already have Olivia before
it's also a mistake are we thinking
about some well it's maybe Marshall it
was to play time chittering III just try
and make sure everything's how was it
either
oh yeah I think the trailers better
mm-hmm yeah cuz later on it just seemed
like cuz after Bishop c4 I there was a
nice move I found it in Bishop c5 no I'm
threatening to play Queen g3 and at some
point other type one like he played King
f1 and Queen before now G efforts
hanging so he have to take his queen
from d1 square when you and he gave me
the d2 it's super-important square
because now like I am controlling like
everything and attacking f2 poem also
Bishop on e4 has no squares now yeah it
seems like very instructive yes I was
already done when the wing because
especially in time me I'm not sure if
it's possible to hold this position but
my Auckland was in time travel so yeah
from all right I've got practical
standpoint I mean it's just so many
headaches for white to jail and d5 aunty
yeah if we go forward here and seems
like the the finish was was pretty nice
for you all right here actually if it
takes on G I prefer to play it for
because for example if to play at five
there was an option to play into the
pitch for know there are squinty to move
and it's not so easy already because now
it's raining the Queen's or if Queen you
want Bishop Bishop I mean it can be
winning also but it's not as simple as
after h4 mmm-hmm now if takes I can take
wish a [ __ ] first engage that was
important oh here I was a bit surprised
you put your king on the light square
but because I checked now can get rate
and after in variation like twitch work
finish one Queen d1 and d3 will be
hanging so after this yeah so if now
Queen h4 h4 in h1 21 and that was the
point it's a nice little trick this
Bishop it's a just loose on d3
so he played a yes king was forced yeah
let's imagine my cat played King h8 or
some other movie he could have like when
you have six check here
aha I'm not sure maybe that's also good
that I can play king jet but I decided I
thought it's winning again we should be
123 that's very beautiful finish like
the bishop just so passive on d1 so
congratulations on a very nice start
what was your preparation going into
this event
I know pairings went up well before
today have you prepared for each player
are you going to take it one day before
a tournament I took a short look oh my
my opens openings but I don't like to
prepare before because I have a lot of
time here at morale and I think
configuring a day so 3 and when you're
preparing before it around your it's
easier to memorize your preparation
that's very true and last question have
you had a chance or will you have the
chance to do anything non chest related
and perhaps a bit more fun in st. Louis
during these next several days I hope so
well I'm not planning to sit all day in
my room and just chest
I plan on don't hate me for what to do
and oh right now but I'll ask my friends
who have been here some activities
sounds good well congrats again on the
start and we're going to take a quick
commercial break and we'll be back with
more coverage from the 2018 fall chess
classic
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premiere gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
hello and welcome back to the 2018 fall
chess classic right here in st. Louis
Missouri my name is Ben Simon along with
international master and notable
streamer Eric Rosen Eric we have a game
in Group B that was on the verge of
being clinched by one of the youngsters
it's true the the heated matchup between
Christopher you and Brandon Jacobson
things were sharp earlier and now it
seems like some pieces have come off the
board in Jacobson's favor let's take a
look at the current position and I just
want to take a quick pause here to count
material and see that black has an extra
minor piece and white only has a pawn
for it and black also has a bishop hair
so it seems like Brandon should be
cruising to victory assuming there's no
there's no sneaky tricks from the white
side I do want to go back and see how
the game unfolded going to the moment
when black played rook see - we were
admiring like very beautiful combination
of pawn and rook in White's territory
and let's get to the moment where black
one material seems like why it was just
quite passive Queen b5 just have a
poking move attacking the rook which is
loose on d3 Queen III and the nice
centralizing move Queen to e5 and just
seems like why it is is holding on for
dear life
rook t4 was played Queen goes back to c5
some nice alignment here with the Queen
aligned on the same diagonal with all of
White's major pieces this rook is a bit
pinned on d4 so white cannot immediately
take the bishop on a4 queen d3 played
unpinning the rook from the Queen but
there's still a pin so the rook on g1
after Bishop to b5 I think this is a
moment where things start start getting
messy after Queen take b3 rook take d2 a
nice tactic from from black taking
advantage of the pin maybe this was
overlooked by White's
we can see that there's just so much
pressure that the combination of Bishop
Queen and rook targeting so many loose
things in White's position with Queen
III have helped queen III looks like an
attempt to keep everything defended it
seems like there could be maybe one more
straw that can break the camel's back in
this position with the move like plenty
five and now the pin just seems too
devastating and with this Queen well
defended on c5 rook d3 would just run
into Bishop to e3 so I assume this is
what Christopher was scared of so he he
did take on b3 going down a piece trying
to get as much compensation as possible
but okay black takes on g1 keeps
initiative between returns to c5 and I
wouldn't be surprised if this game ends
relatively shortly
it is Brandon's move though and they're
both in time trouble there they're still
still behind move 40 they're on move 33
seven more moves to go until time
pressure
Christopher kind of shifting around and
is fair they're playing with both a
couple of pieces off the board it's a
bit mesmerizing to look at is this a
psychological tactic here is this just
nerves I mean if I was sitting across
from the night I would be so mad
mesmerised on the pieces twirling in his
hands
maybe trying to hypnotize his opponents
but Brandon does play a move actually a
few moves have been play at King g7 was
played at some point
oh the lot well that moves had been
played rook to c2 who then I came to f5
another instance of knife f5 let's get
to the current position because it seems
like White's scanning a bit activity but
probably not enough and white still down
the piece of rooks are off the board
Christopher just played Knight d4
my apologies more moves have been played
let's update the position 94 bishop c6
Knight takes c6
King takes c6 and black is just up a
fold Bishop I think at this point it's
just just hoping for a miracle
from the white side given that this
should be a relatively easy conversion
for back but Christopher is making the
most of it queen bee aids jumping into
the territory of the box side hitting
the bishop and I think White's hope is a
fact that this bishop is out of play and
the king is very exposed on c6 and we
saw this in the Stevens urk kibou Xion
game too
when a king is exposed and there's still
a queen on the board you have to be very
careful of an onslaught of checks in
this case black will maybe have to work
to get out of some perpetual some
potential perpetual with the Queen
planning to come perhaps to see AIT's to
aid there's lots of potential checking
ideas and it would be a blunder if that
moves the Bishop to e7
given that Queen e8 is just a simple
fork so it looks like they finally have
reached move 40 let me update the board
again and see where they're at going
back let's say they're almost there
Greene b8 Bishop h6 looks like this is a
current position 39th move both players
hovering around a minute I wouldn't be
surprised if if one save each time
control light would resign pretty
shortly but who knows we we never assume
that the youngsters are not going to
give up without a fight especially
Christopher you sure he has a lot of
energy to to keep fighting especially in
round one
you see queen c8 was played and king b6
played quite quickly and now it's a
question can black escape the checks
from the white queen
we see Brandon there leaving the board
Christopher still appears to be a bit
nervous but but both players have the
extra half hour to to ponder the
situation might be interesting to
analyze here like what exactly happens
after queen bee AIT's because it seems
like if the king wants to escape the
perpetual in a6 or c6 would just repeat
the position
so maybe the king would be provoked up
to c5 and if light continues with a move
like before it's a bit funny but
blacking probably find shelter in
White's territory if before isn't played
a bee queen before then simply king c6
and maybe the king can start running
this direction that Queen c4 King d7
seems like white is going to at some
point run out of checks just imagining
some line where the king is probably
going to find safety on g6 well another
player with white that is in really big
trouble right now is hammer if that game
isn't over already Eric Hanson in Group
A is looking really good he's got a
queen and a rook on his seventh rank and
this looks very pleasing for black right
I guess the game is still in progress
and there we see the the shot of the
players Eric very still very focused and
they they have reached time control they
just reached move 40 this is a time of
the round where players will be reaching
the 40 move more gaining extra time and
then having a lot more time to ponder
these various endgame positions
I very much like Eric setup given that I
mean when you have two major pieces on
the second-ranked especially with the
Queen's fall on the board there's going
to be some
some potential mating ideas for the time
being white does have all the squares in
front of the king defended the rook
defends f2 the knight defends g2 the
Queen's defends h2 but what this also
means is all of White's pieces are tied
down and none of none of the pieces have
much mobility given that there's so many
potential threats on the second-ranked
and if black can just remove one of
these pieces a knight the rook or the
queen
it could be lights out for for hammer so
as black I would be looking here for
some way to use this Knights as a more
more aggressive attacking piece I
thought originally Knight f3 because if
the Queen takes and you know you can
made on h2 but the the rook would have
to take a 3-0 to go through right yes
okay and it's White's move and hammer
does not look so pleased Hansen has left
the board and just hammer with his head
in his hand can't be too happy about
this position doesn't seem like there's
any active play of white would like to
generate some counter play but F sevens
defended this might has defended on e5
by the Queen and a move like knife 5
which we've seen already a few times in
this round noble attacking move just
doesn't work because Queen g2 mates so I
wouldn't be happy if I was if I was in
white situation here
so we can expect I mean do you think
Hummers gonna resign here soon I mean a
sequel material and assuming that
there's no immediate tactical glow
I would think he's gonna try and fight
on I mean his one hope is that if Queens
got traded then maybe there's some
drawing chances the problem is there's
no way to force a Queen trade and I'm
actually trying to find a move here for
whites that doesn't lose immediately I
didn't even think of this before it but
it might I mean there might be some
zhulong potential here given that so
many things are tied down I mean the
site has no moves like moves anywhere
there's Queen G two mates the rook on
the other hand it can't move to f2 it
can't really move along the first ring
because Queen f2 and moving along the F
file doesn't seem to be of any purpose
there's no progress to make here right I
mean well white would just be shuffling
it's finally Applewhite might have to
shuffle queen or king each one maybe but
that looks like such a sad move and
meanwhile it's all it's gonna be all up
to black to figure out the the way just
to crash through so we see hammer and
not even looking at the board just his
head off to the side maybe glancing at
some other games doesn't want to look at
the position in front of him I've been
in the situation before many times
myself and sometimes you just and you
you can't you can't undo the past
there's no time machine to go back
several moves earlier so just has to
move forward and maybe realize his
mistakes and move on I'm curious we just
saw hammer looking at the board next to
him is there ever a case where a player
is on move and they are simply waiting
for the opponent to return so they can
resign I've been in that situation
before where my opponent leaves and I'm
about to resign and then it puts me in
an awkward situation
like do I resign and then go up and
shake his hand if I'm about to resign I
usually just play a move to provoke my
opponent to come
I mean maybe I'll wait for them to play
one more move because I don't like
resigning on my opponents move and then
I'll just shake hands sure but well I'm
also the type of player I like to fight
even when things seem hopeless I would
certainly not resign in this position
I'd probably play a move like king h1 or
maybe something like Queen
I don't know Queen h-2b also seemed sad
but I I would at least play on some more
moves to see how black is actually in
the win this position Eric we have a
result and it comes from Group B once
more Akshat Chandra has lost with white
and Belarus Belarusian Sergey Azeroth
gets the victory we have not looked at
that game yet right I don't we have not
no AK Chandra a st. Louis local I saw
him before the round he looked he looked
under eyes he looked ready to fight but
we can we see this fight this final
position is quite reasonable the the
knight is attacked three times on c3 and
it's pinned to the Queen yeah seems
pretty hopeless here maybe we can go
back I'm not sure how the game unfolded
it was another one of these Catalan
games we haven't been taking a look at
too many openings in in too many of the
games so far but the the trademark of
the Catalan with the bishop in Catalan
on g2 has occurred of in a few games so
far and this game went in inbox favor
let's play forward here because there's
a lot of tension in the position and it
seems like black is the one expanding in
the center
it's Pawnee form move just completely
shutting down this really sad bishop now
on g2 after Bishop take off six Queen
take off six black black gets the bishop
pair and just seems like by this passive
this reminds me a little bit of the
Stephens art game where black is a1
activating the pieces from early on
and whites pieces not the best
coordinated a group of pieces with the
Queen kind of out of play on b1 and
black is the one building a pressure
it's either if there are further
exchanges here and the rook activates on
D - now this queen is severely out of
play and there's already threats against
this f2 pawn going forward here Brooke
f1 seemed like pretty much forced move
rook b2 very nice move taking advantage
of the fact Queen is controlling B 2 and
this b3 pawn is loose Queen d3 was
played after Bishop taking for quaint a
key for rook take b3 black just goes up
a clean pawn keeping the initiative and
seems like everything worked out well
for black sometimes when your pieces
aren't by the squares and there's a lot
of lot of chaos in the position a lot of
trades and forcing lines the outcome
will ultimately benefit the side who is
better placed and it seems like that's
what happened in this game pollinate for
the rook plants itself on d4 I'm curious
how this was super pin developed at the
end yeah I mean it seemed like black
just kept the pressure like these pieces
are just so well coordinated another
instance where everything in blacks
position is defended and this whole
setup with Bishop on c5 supported by the
b6 pawn the rook supported by the pawn
and the bishop on from before just seems
like Bach has everything under control
h4 not sure what that accomplishes but
very possible white is just stuck here
and positions like this are a bit
torturous when this stock you have no
active play and sometimes that can
induce further mistakes this case a
knight went back to c3 and then after
Queen ePHI of just centralizing the
Queen's maybe even thinking of some
ideas of of taking on e3 also getting
out of any potential 95 check should go
back and point out light was threatening
95 so Queen e5 is a nice prophylactic
move restricting the Knights perhaps
preparing Queen
herring rook to c4 which was ultimately
played in the game rook d1 rook c4 and I
think at this point it's just about her
just about over
rook d3 Bishop b4 and Chandra resigns no
more support
yes I'd finished her for auction but a
very good start for Azara of who if I'm
not mistaken I don't recall as art of
playing in the st. Louis event before
he's a completely new name to me yeah so
so no I don't believe that he has I've
played him once many years ago in a
blitz tournament in Washington DC and I
remember playing him and just getting
completely outplayed both games I
believe I lost 0 to 2 was a double round
event so I know he's a dangerous
opponent and not only dangerous to me
but clearly dangerous to the opponents
in this field as well yeah for sure now
I I'm looking at hammer and he handsome
again the engine is calculating to mate
this is looks like a foregone conclusion
here sorry everybody out there in the
chat yeah let's go back to so the
current position we see ya the what a
sad move king h1 almost as sad as
hammers expression during the game and
after Queen d2 just slowly building a
pressure just perhaps poking at the
knight on III the night is completely
tied down and that's a question how does
white deal with a simple threat of Queen
Tech III should point out here that if
Queen take e3 either is queen take E 5
but then there's probably Queen e2 and
so Queen taking 3 is probably a strong
threat and I'm not sure I'm not sure
what does here yet again
seems like Eric is just so comfortable
just not even looking at the board okay
now he's looking at the board maybe just
waiting for her hammer to resign I know
I'm sure the people watching online
there it is probably a large focus
especially on this game given that not
too often we can see hammer play against
Hansen in and over the board game right
yeah this is actually Amy could you call
this a dream game perhaps maybe that's a
little over exaggeration but I mean out
of the whole field in group a I think
these two players have the biggest
online personalities I mean they're both
very well followed on Twitch very active
on chess calm I mean Hansen part of the
notorious chess brahs who not mistaken
recently got a place in st. Louis so oh
they're everywhere
they are everywhere that's very true it
would be interesting to hear from the
chats on YouTube and twitch who they're
rooting for who they're they're looking
to see win it's hard there's a lot of
interest in this game then there's a lot
of people rooting for the chest bra Eric
Hansen sure and yeah the conversation is
kind of died down over this thing see
it's a lot essentially we got a question
earlier from twitch and unfortunately I
don't have the submitters name they
asked the Ehlo rating of the pumpkin of
the pumpkin yes well there is a sticker
on the pumpkin I don't know if people
can see this it says nine three one
three four not sure what exactly that
means but seems like a pretty high
rating okay there we see the game has
ended Mike Hummer putting the kings in
the center of the board taking away the
score sheets seem like hammer just had
enough given that there was no way to
defend against the onslaught of attack
from
Hanson it would be nice to get Eric in
the studio I don't think I've ever
interviewed Eric before and it might be
confusing with with so many Eric's in
the studio but look I think that's a
great idea we can get Erica that'd be
spectacular because you know Eric's a
buddy of mine I'm not gonna lie
Eric and I we both like that Eric Hanson
yeah we both like to watch MMA
we're both pro wrestling fans you have
many interests outside of heads yeah you
know what kind of friends but as I was
saying this is a it's not a good chess
player it's a it's a pumpkin
it's true only 99 cents I remember
everyone follow us online join the
conversation with hashtag fall chess
classic we are not gonna be with you too
much longer today but the picture of the
round is taking shape indeed we have
Eric Hanson with the lone victory in a
thus far I think the pumpkin deserves
less focus and the players deserve more
focus at least for now because there are
positions heating up absolutely I do
want to go back to this game between Al
Shean and and Dennis because things are
getting very sharp I was only taking her
glance at this game earlier seems like
the position has transformed
tremendously maybe we can go back just
to quickly try and evaluate in this
current position accounting material
here White has what White has one to
five pawns against three pawns but white
is down a knight so black does have the
material advantage but visually I really
like White's chances here I mean as pawn
on f5 undefendable combined with the
idea of Bishop c2 this seems like a bad
bad moment for white
so if we go back let's see how the game
unfolded let's actually jump back to
where left off before because we saw a
nice sort of French structure for whites
very nice Bishop controlling the long
diagonal very bad to bishops for black
normally close positions bishops are not
such happy pieces in this case both of
box bishops very passive I will note
White's Bishop is passive it doesn't it
doesn't matter too much because a bishop
does keep d4 supported so going forward
here f6 is played a very typical French
move to make this joke again not a move
that than fine gold would be happy about
94 is played I really like this move
just applying pressure from multiple
directions there's no three attackers on
the f6 pawn pawn off I've played the
knight retreats and I think what white
did was just provoke f5 given that
there's now a target to attack the pawn
on f5 can now be perhaps removed as we
see White's next move pawn g4
just breaking open the position not only
trying to open up the diagonal but also
trying to open up the the G file for a
potential King h1 in 31 so seems like
White has a lot a lot of pressure from
this position now unfortunately I don't
have time to go through the whole whole
series here because we do have a special
guest in the studio
welcome to Eric Hanson and
congratulations on a very nice victory
in round 1 thank you now I do have to
ask you just came back from
batumi yes how was your experience there
and are you still overcoming some some
jet lag definitely some jet lag I think
it's 9 hours something like that
on the other hand it was my first
tournament in over a year so this is I'm
not as rusty as I was in Batumi and at
least I feel a bit more fresh but yeah
otherwise the travel was like 30 hours
and I was it was pretty rough I I'm
happy that I don't know what today's
game was a lot more worried that it
could have gone in a different direction
because I didn't have much time to
prepare but fair enough
and I I do want to ask because I was
surprised to see you on the list as not
having a world ranking because you're
inactive yes are you making a comeback
to tournament rest so you're gonna stick
with the streaming as long as possible I
wasn't planning on coming back I had the
Olympiad and I had this tournament just
I have to play the Olympiad and I
thought I might as well play in st.
Louis I've been invited a few times but
the scheduling didn't work I was going
to take a break after that or continue
my semi retirement but it was so
embarrassing the way I played in at the
Olympia that made it a goal to play more
actually and yeah try to actually push
myself and play chess so it's a very
recent decision that I now looking to
play tournaments and compete with some
of the better players
fair enough and hopefully you're warmed
up and perhaps taking some momentum from
this first round win take us through the
game it seemed like a somewhat unusual
night good thing was plays everything so
I just didn't prepare for the game and I
didn't feel the need to because he's
been he's been mixing it up and I when
he played you for I was like well we
placed so much online and everywhere
that might as well play something I
haven't played so I decided to go with
the Sicilian and just see what he what
he went for in the g3 is pretty common
these days what I like about the line is
it seems like there's some pretty
dynamic play for both sides and there
were some fun games at the Olympiad that
I was watching we're just all three
results were in plays so I thought I
thought now that I was a bit like I
wasn't rusty that I might as well play
more in my energetic style so it felt
like the type of position
where both sides get to do what they
want and and I must say the main thing
about the opening here I was happy to
give away the bishop because I just the
spent around 30 40 minutes when you play
95 debating if I should keep the bishop
or not I've seen people play here
instead of Bishop d7 I think Knight
takes d5 Queen takes d5 Rick a7 Bishop
b3 there should be six let's say Queen
d2 I was thinking and now rook p7 rook
d7 let's say rook d7 and I've never had
one of these positions but I've seen
something like it and I mean it looked
maybe okay but I wasn't sure if I could
get in d5 properly and felt like white
had a little bit more control I'm not
used to playing with a rook on d7 and
that on let's say c6 so maybe this is
playable I think I've seen some games
like that but I decided to go for a more
provocative approach giving away the
bishop and the main reason I went for
this is Knight age 4 was not a concern
for me and that's what took me a long
time to realize that after Queen e6
tonight Knight f5 is hard to achieve so
what say Knight f5 right away originally
I didn't even think you could do this
but the point being here if I take on e4
with let's say the night
there's queen g4
after well I can't block of queen g6 and
if g6 just Bishop Dixie for my rook on
the a it's hanging and so the tactics
don't work out for me but instead and
the same thing if Bishop takes a four
just take and queen reversed oh yeah and
I don't know it didn't didn't look good
but instead of that I was just gonna
play d5 which is typical to undermine
but the one thing I was looking at was
hey what about Bishop h3 because maybe
it's awkward but after King h8 I was
like actually a much of that and it's
very good there at all because it's
actually pinned and unless there's
something strong that you can do right
here then you for is following and also
I can even play g6 in some lines but
that night just can't move so I this was
the realization that made me go for this
position then I get really active even
though black White has the two bishops I
didn't see a really good way to utilize
them and I get d5 very quickly so in the
game yeah for example so but then the
knight on h4 isn't that strong if f5 is
in key square so I played 97 could have
played I can try to play d5 in some
variations and it was probably like fine
for me usually you want to do that but I
was at this point I was already feeling
good so 97 Queen e2 rook c8 and
see three rooks see four I wanted to
sacrifice in exchange there was a game
in the Olympiad a teammate of ours in
Montreal Yvan Sarich from Croatia he was
playing black and he just sacrificed
this rook for that LightSquared bishop
and got like winning position you know
very slow just to take on you for yeah
just that like just a very similar
position and and you got it very very
comfortable game against what's thinking
you might want to play Bishop yeah for
me for I mean in in this case of I'll
just take with the bishop but as an
example rook takes see for just the
light squares are so weak that that
would also be a possibility because
whites rooks aren't that useful so he
played out three which was forced and
after d5 and this just seemed very much
it is yeah especially after f3 in night
h4 it seems like white is not finding
any harmony for sure and the yeah I mean
this all seems pretty force and I was
like well I'm very active I have a lot
of possibilities here I didn't exactly
know what to do the one thing that I've
had issues with being rusty is time
trouble so around here I was trying to
catch up the bit I was down on the clock
23 minutes and I just played natural
moves instead of calculating like one
thing I want to do let's say instead of
rook e8 let's just say rook back to see
it
it's rook c8 yeah I mean it sounds
pretty funny but I wanted to play
something like first of all II too might
be free but otherwise Bishop c4 and 95
is another threat because the Queen is
running out of real estate there and
this was also pretty tempting because
right now there's no time to play b3 c3
is hanging in this line there's some
moves like Bishop h3 that maybe it kicks
me off but I would be fairly similar to
the game and yeah I thought I thought
this definitely deserves consideration
and maybe I should have gone for it but
yeah there's just a bunch of pleasant
options and I just went for the natural
moves put my rook on yet because well
the night if it ever gets to have five
will threaten 97 check so just cover my
bases so at what point do you feel like
the game was really turning in your
favor like clearly have a pleasant
position here but when was a decisive
moment I played all the easy
and after a five after I played a five I
realized well we're both getting low on
time like thirty minutes for that said
20 moves and a four is a pretty serious
strategical threat here
it's just run out of easy moves himself
I've run out of most with my pieces but
a five is a great move to try to open up
this diagonal around here I thought he
had to do something critical because a
force coming and you can't let me when
the a pawn you can't let me put a piece
on c4 probably also you're just like
fish what's the bishop doing on G -
what's a knight doing on h4 so I thought
black had a very good position here and
why not to go for something desperate
because you just don't want to play so
passively especially as you get down on
time because at some point I may play
efore I never play d4 because well it
gives him the weekends maybe you can
take and his pieces are too many squares
but later on he forced always a movie
has to consider and I just thought the
tension was was unpleasant to deal with
so it made sense that he decided to go
for something concrete and I think this
was very interesting
it's a pawn sacrifice to activate all
the pieces and I didn't want to win upon
I'd much rather keep him in a bind so
for example instead of Bishop takes c4 I
also take once this should be six would
be like in the ideal situation I would I
would take this let's say Bishop takes
rook takes I want to keep the option of
Queen c5 checks so that a5 is defended
maybe just Knight f5 it doesn't look
pretty for for white but he's traded off
some pieces and I still need some sort
of breakthrough still takes work yeah
it's this still looks good for me but I
couldn't decide and I decided I'll just
take the pawn a pawn driver
I don't usually don't do that and are
you influenced by yasser by any means by
usually a lot but in this case I was
getting a long time and I was like I'm
definitely better if I take if I go for
this but
his he gets active now and it's
pointless because now tonight you seven
checkers sometimes in the air if I move
my bishop there's rook takes c8 at 96
working Myrick and queen so my pieces
are a little bit pinned here and the h6
move is well I can't kick away the
knight from that five with with pawns Oh
white sacrifice the pawns was for a lot
of activity and here I thought I mean I
thought what he did made a lot of sense
if this isn't good for white then I
think you're just in a very bad position
yeah we go into this position where I
went upon it's all forced here I was
considering Ricky to be a to try to be
fancy but we're just a lot of time I'm
just trying to it seems like in the
first round players are more likely to
get into time trouble than later round
yes is there a way to like cope with
that maybe be a bit more warmed up going
into the first round as well well he was
really in the first half and it's only
when it was a little uncomfortable he
started taking some more time especially
fear there's some concrete things sure
for me just playing a tournament before
I helped but the Olympiad I was really
shaking beginning of that and so I
always try to warm up some some way and
I think yeah I mean in this case well
seem like the finish was just amazing
for you with such dominant well here I
wasn't confident as I mean I was happy
that it's to result game but it's a pawn
on the same side of the board and and
what what I wasn't sure for example is
uh is he cut the bishop on but that also
gives me more possibilities with my
Knights because I gotta and you could
have traded the bishop for my knight on
g7 and played an unpleasant endgame
especially because it's Kings a little
bit weak so as long as I keep the Queen
in the rook black has practical chances
but by keeping the bishop on the bishops
not necessarily good piece and I'm
playing you for here and it just shows
my Knights got soup very very active and
as you get it you know time trouble
everyone knows how tricky Knights are
but here the problem is this King is
actually weak so let's say he didn't
take
but if it takes 90 ticks let's say
Knight Bishop takes Knight X and try to
trade Queens it's a Queen c2 I'll put my
queen on v6 and you're just dealing with
some serious suffering here because no
matter where you put your king it's
going to be exposed
this looks painful yeah it looks very
people maybe in Queen d4 actually put we
go back on I can't I couldn't do for ya
something on the diagonal but yeah I'm
gonna get some some long-term pressure
it seems like situations like this the
advantage of King safety is more
valuable than the advantage of having an
extra pawn of course both make it just
so much better for blacks so here's you
didn't want this my knight can go to g5
+ f3 an h3 get really weak dependence
strong it's hard to hold this looks
really bad
and so e4 is nice nice move job just
pretty good before it was really
necessary especially because I actually
don't have another move because he's
covering everything now 93 I didn't
calculate ETA x f3 I was just thinking
about this after the game I guess
there's some sort of back rank stuff so
this was his trick he takes f3 or XE v
and I guess he has some sort of rook c8
check hoping to liquidate everything so
let's say rook takes rook check and
maybe this is fun for me maybe I have 98
and maybe I shouldn't go for this looks
a little bit scary but maybe not look it
looks yeah I didn't calculate this maybe
this works as well but what I did was
very natural 93 his rook has to go back
and now rook 8 a one I was just down to
like a few seconds here I made a mistake
here there's a very cool variation that
I think works although maybe I have
something better F takes e4 set up
bishop takes and the idea is rookie - we
play like the game you thought is Bishop
but we got Queen d1
Queen B - I now Queen c2
and the point is first of all he's
starting Quincy admit but if I trade
everything there which looks great
he is a five in the end to take take
critics and you finding everything and I
didn't have much time and I might have
allowed this but then this is uh this is
just the whites okay yeah why it's okay
but he's starting made at the same time
if I don't like we'd be too I mean when
the Queen's on so I I have to find a
different variation and black is still
pushing because he's got the second rank
about up on search and everything but I
only had a few seconds so if I went for
this line and he found that then I would
have lost it so I was something still
felt bad about my conversion but it
doesn't make sense to take on you for
with the pawn unless you see that
because yeah your Bishop on on f5 can be
blockaded in some lines and yeah much
more natural to help with the bishop but
okay the resulting position I think is
now is just forced now so much worse
well just lost Queen Queen B to Queen
age 595 and using I mean I don't need to
find a win right away he just has no
moves seem close to live long yeah it's
gonna be sucked about at some at some
point yeah there's just no moves because
every piece is doing that defensive well
what's what's just only defending but
there's no perpetual so I can even go
peace hunting because I never knee five
just saves like just does everything
right everything's tied down for life
and this was move forty so this was very
nice because then I could sit back relax
and we saw that on the the Robo can we
were relaxing yeah in the walk and he
was just looking so so sad yeah no
person for there's just no moves I can't
say this was all planned for me and as I
said there was a bit of a shaky
conversion
I was happy with the pressure I put on
yeah I was telling myself even if I
don't win this game playing
energetically playing a little bit
faster those are some positives isn't
the to me onsen I was a time trouble
addict sure now I do want to ask do you
know your your lifetime score against
hammer in online play I'm sure it could
be I looked you get usually got the
better of him it's pretty back and forth
we've had some like Heartbreakers I beat
him in a key match in the pro league we
beat him in Magnus 13 very nice because
of my final game against them he'd beat
me in a death match this year with a
pretty epic comeback we've traded a lot
of wins and losses so I would say I
would say generally we're pretty pretty
close pretty competitive and I always
enjoy playing them and one last question
will you be doing any sort of streaming
or vlogging during this treatment are
you gonna like but this is the strongest
Herman I've ever played in 2650 whatever
new average rating and I've been away
for a month from North America and I'm
hoping maybe up on streams and maybe
maybe some other people covered but for
myself I don't think I can manage
playing against such a strong opponents
in streaming at the same time I'm hoping
you guys are covering which is really
nice and and we'll see what we do in our
channel but I'll try to focus because I
don't have any tournaments after this so
this one I'll I'll I'll try to put put
some good effort in and
I can get back this room after with
determination sounds good well we won't
keep you here any longer
Congrats again on winning the first game
and best of luck in the rest of your
ends thank you
so we're gonna move on here and take a
look there's been a number of games
still finished I do want to take a look
at the game between Alshon Marzia body
and Dennis Poros that ended decisively
in an out Shawn's favor seems like a
pretty brutal finish white being gone a
piece in the final position but let's
just go back a few moves and see how
this unfolded after after the Queen
actually after the pawn lands on each
six the bishop was forced to retreat
this is a very nice configuration for
light where the pawns on dark square is
really restrict this starts for Bishop
which is one of the lone defenders of
the blocking side after Bishop f8 Queen
is happy to take on a five King g8 a
queen g6 check and we see that a black
is just going down pretty hard here I
can imagine if King eight shades there
would be maybe some move like this
should take g5 taking advantage of the
pin maybe even someone's like the ship
c2 threatening mate on c2 so very good
start for El Shawn so I do want to
welcome back Ben Simon to the studio oh
hello Ben I know you just had a nice
break if you have any results for us any
any progress with either group so far
this has been a bloody day okay this is
gonna be a fun tournament I can tell
already because Group B looks to be 100%
decisive after this is over and group a
isn't that far off there's only one
group that I'm sorry there's only one
game left in B but besides the victory
that L Shawn had over Boris we had
Ashwin Jha ROM taking on Conrad holt and
Ashwin got the victory there I think we
have glanced
we did not we were not looking at that
game Ashwin is a former teammate of mine
having attended back through University
and he now lives and works in st. Louis
going back here it seemed like a
somewhat dry rook end game the position
they had around move 30 just seems very
Josh but perhaps a slight pole for light
given that black does have double pawns
on the queenside also the fact that
life's rook is simply more active than
blacks row so sometimes you can take up
like small advantages in these rook
endings and convert them to much larger
advantages I don't know if we can get
the board up here yeah let's see if we
can have a Schwinns game with Conrad up
on the screen would just there we go I'm
gonna say for the time being people can
admire the Pope yes I think people are
probably more interested in the chest so
Wow so they went into a a King pawn
ending pretty abruptly rook to e6 this
is a type of move that if you're a
grandmaster and you're about to go into
a King pawn ending you should be at the
ability where you can calculate and know
whether it's winning or drawn now this
King pawn ending seems pretty complex
just on the surface because there's a
number of ways black can activate the
King and I would imagine that Oswin took
a lot of time to capture on u6 knowing
that it's a very committal move now of
course white is the one clearly playing
for a win here given that black's pawn
structure across the board is shattered
and going back to the premise of pawn
islands these are two very very scenic
pawn islands as you'd say it's well put
together
no no immediate weaknesses for whites so
let's see how play unfolded both sides
activate the Kings Conrad gets to his
King to the center first and sometimes
it becomes a game of who runs out of
time earlier
where the Kings got into some opposition
situation and then it's a matter of
making waiting moves and from next
several moves both sides pushed some
pawns a three simply a waiting move pawn
on e5 f3 this is a nice move to restrict
the epon from advancing further black
advances on the kingside pawn b3 pawn d5
King III and now we're in a situation
where it seems like black is running out
of moves given that there's only so many
pawns left to push really just a b7 h7
pawn and if the black King ever moves
from this configuration it would give
away the e4 square which is a very
valuable square for the white king and
it looks like this is what happened
seems like accurate play by ashwin just
simply waiting King g3 nice move and the
King White King penetrates King g6 King
f5 and White's King just gets in sooner
and now it becomes a race where white is
is just so much faster at piggy picking
up the H pawn and then soon to Queen his
own H pawn just a few more moves were
played before nice way to just slow down
black on the Queen side and this is just
it's like a cheetah versus a turtle or
the cheetah runs down the H file the
turtle is just too slow on the Queen
side so nice and I start by by Austrian
geography yeah you know the first time I
ever met Ashwin actually it was right
here at the club and he had won a
millionaire chess satellite I think it
was for the first millionaire chest back
in 2014 with a lot of hoopla so he you
know it's nice to see him back here
doing well we already took a final look
at Group B if we can do we have the
results for Group A as they are I know
three games are pending
yes so Eric Hansen of course with the
lone victory thus far it looks like we
might have a couple more victories
though drove and spirits are in good
shape and
[Music]
and then Akopian and Robson drew earlier
today but we don't have much time left
for today so it's just about time to say
goodbye Eric
that's right we should make a note that
if viewers want to continue watching the
games you can do so at us chess chance
comm there's links to the chess 24 link
you can also re-watch the the broadcast
on YouTube or twitch I believe the games
are also being broadcast on me chess org
which then gives you access to stock
fish and the opening database and table
base so lots of ways to keep up with
action you really have your pick however
you want it you can have it so that will
do it for today remember the rest of the
rounds up until the final round are
later than they were today tomorrow the
round starts at 1:00 p.m. Central Time
and we will be on the air at 3:30 p.m.
Central time for our 90-minute wrap-up
show ok well that will do it for today
for international master Eric Rosen I'm
Ben Simon this show was produced by the
world's greatest production B team
Tammy Hyde is the streamer Keith Haley
was a huge assistant in getting our
cameras working today
Eric Mosel is the designer of the show
Isaac's trance graphics and audio and
Danny Machuca is your technical director
so until tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. Central
we say so long from the show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you